thanks Nikki okay so this is going to be
a talk on open problems that's what
Nikki what we talked about some open
problems in the display arts marketplace
these are not necessarily not all of
them were like fully fleshed out
concrete math problems I'm going to talk
about practical challenges that we face
in the marketplace
but I'm sure there are many problems out
there that this community can solve so
these are current problems many of these
are like real like we are talk tacking
these right now okay so what are the
entities in the marketplace
this is a pretty messy marketplace there
are too many entities okay the big the
okay the most important ones are the
publishers so when you say publishers
they think of like this big newspaper
publishers New York Times Washington
Post or Gannett but we often don't think
of these app publishers and these are
actually pretty huge many of them are
like multi-billion dollar market cap
companies and they are completely on
fire now and there is a diversity there
is like distinction between you know the
regular publishers and app publishers
and that you know gives rise to some
important problems that we're talking
about today okay so this is one of the
big entities in the marketplace of
course there are advertisers you know
who want to maximize their ROI reach and
scale etc and there are end users and
there is an awful lot of each of these
okay we are talking about this is like
very very concentrated really 100-plus
billion page views per day thousands of
advertisers are so many publishers and
there are so many companies out there
trying to maximize metrics for all these
like relevance for you
users revenue for publishers our Owen
reads the scale further so these are
sort of the main entities but of course
there are you know entities which
represent these so there are sell side
platforms these are platforms which
represent publishers like many of them
you know Google ad manager is one very
big one and there are separate sell side
platforms for a publishers for instance
both were born by Twitter is a big
platform sell side platform for app apps
so these app publishers will get an
account here and then through the single
platform they are able to sort of
completely manage all their demand
sources right whoever is buying from
them very Nevada admit it's getting sold
all the revenues that are like nice
reporting is being given they still say
platforms ok and then likewise on the
buy side there are demand-side platforms
which try to advocate for a given buyer
if you're buying across several
different publishers several different
exchanges etcetera you don't want to you
know have the burden of doing this see
what demand side platform which will
give you beautiful reporting which will
take care of bidding optimizations for
you you know many advertisers don't even
have the fire rose to like sort of don't
even have the bandwidth to take the
Google fire rose for instance and these
bidding networks can do that like for
instance crateros managing more than big
billion all these are like really big so
I'll use the word demand-side platforms
and ad networks interchangeably and then
there are marketplaces which our
exchanges I had exchanges which run some
kind of auction so whenever you visit a
query you go and visit New York Times
and then that query central exit Google
ID X in Google Analytics sends a call
out to all these bidding networks and
they have to bid all this happens in
real time in real time this bidding
network's design a bit some kind of
auction goes on and then you decide the
winner the ad is impressed
so what this cárdenas ok ok let's talk
about problems now mediation is one big
problem so mediation itself is not a
problem the problem comes to the next
slide ok so what exactly is mediation
like I said publishers are getting ads
from numerous different act sources it's
not just one act so
it's not just critical or Facebook
audience Network alone that I want to
get my money from its numerous ad
sources and unfortunately there is not
enough demand aggregation right there is
not a single flat auction which where
you could get all these ad networks to
participate and get your money if that
is the case then it's good but we don't
have it we're slowly getting there that
is exchange building that Google has but
still like it's on the desktop space on
the app space that is not enough demand
aggregation so there are so many
different demand sources and as the
publisher of course it's better for me
if you know there is more competition
and more demand sources for the single
query that I'm selling so well what do I
do you know I did I would hope for this
aggregation but since it's not there I'm
going to approach these buyers in
sequence in some kind of chain okay and
then there are companies which are
providing this as a solution so it's a
mediation provider who will do the
following for you as a publisher when a
query comes you send this query to a
mediation provider for you like more pop
for instance coax this this mediation
provider is going to say okay there are
all these demand sources and I'm going
to construct a chain and then I'm going
to call these like different ad networks
in this order a different reserve price
is perhaps right the minimum they have
to bid to win that query all that is
decided by the mediation provider now
many of them out there and primarily
adopted by app publishers because
already the real-time thing is already
challenging on top of this we are
talking about like multiple
back-and-forth yet you send it to an ad
network they're on their own auction get
it back to you and then if it fails you
go to another ad network and so on this
could go on for like 20 30 even 50 times
right so this causes enormous delay and
this terrible experience in desktop but
for apps it's not a problem because
you're going to spend some time on the
app and I'm already fetching it you know
extend minutes I'll start fetching it
right now so in apps this delay is not a
problem and this is adopted by a
publisher so what mediation okay
so what's wrong about this this is okay
but the problem with mediation is that
these mediation providers also do the
following which is that they don't call
an ad network just
the same ad network gets called multiple
times for a single piece of inventory so
the same guys you know and this guy is
there is the same eyeball you are trying
to win there is a single slot and then
you call let's say Google AdMob once hey
do you want to win it at a price of $90
CPM right and then you say no and then
something happens all this is invisible
to you as AdMob and again it comes out
you know do you want to win at 80 for 99
to you same query how do you detect it
and so on we'll come to that this
detection is a huge engineering problem
is unclear but ok so first of all these
chains can be very big the total chain
and sometimes a single demand source
itself could be called like 20 times for
the same piece of inventory
typically at descending prices you
should think of it as an ad network but
it's even for ad exchanges basically
it's Turtles all the way down to ad now
I had exchanged the ad networks anybody
who can return an ad is good enough so
an ID network or Ad Exchange who's
registered with the mediation service
provider right mediation provider here
will be included in this so for instance
Google Ad Exchange for instance is a
part of this chain AdMob is a part of
this chain but Facebook audience network
is not in exchange they are a network
but still they're a part of this chain
so both exchanges I networks are part of
this team it doesn't matter because
ultimately these networks are also
running some internal auctions because
networks represent so many different
buyers in some sense the difference
between exchange and networks gets
blurred there may be exchanges a bigger
in scale the difference is blurred
I think why this is called buy more pop
for instance they are like constructing
change of length 50 and the publisher
can use any mediation service provider
and more pop is one of the big ones for
apps and they construct chains like this
yes yeah they use a single mediation
provider yes and this is also not some
corner case or some like voodoo thing
like HAP's this is the thing if you're
an app publisher you are not doing this
it's basically means that most of your
business is from desktop and your app is
like you know some likes afterthought or
something if you're a big a publisher
this is the thing most of the inventory
is sold by a mediation chains and multi
call is involved no but okay but but the
chain is executed still by on the client
side right like the mesh the for the for
call first goes to mop up and then mop
up will give you a chain and then the
client which is on your phone let's say
and then the client has to like make a
call and then the ad has to come back
with like there's also response time
right you can't like in between a
mediator should not say oh I'll call
this big chain and come back to because
before that response time it will fail
and then mean that that now call failed
that's all in your phone like the chain
is in your phone and then there's decays
are they're very good okay I was going
to say that very good okay so first of
all the colors it's nothing is just that
is the same networker in the same color
right uploading is an ad network is all
of the same color fine its Facebook
audience network is all indirect Google
AdMob isn't green the numbers there are
the reserved prices that I send in the
collect so what is happening here is I
am prying as a publisher or as a
mediation service provider on behalf of
the publisher trying to extract whole
surplus by giving a very high reserve
price at first seeing whether you win
and then I keep on going down in tracer
prices right
it could also be done in parallel but
there are some restrictions on like if
you call out to an ID network and if
they return a winning ad or something
like how often you can like you know
rainy John this promise right because
they're the you know this is a huge cost
to run this operation and then they are
returning an ad and if you say no that's
problematic so you can't run in like you
can arbitrarily call me and every time I
return at a ninety percent of the time
you say no there are some issues there I
addiction is clear right because you're
running an auction
okay so at least for the multi call
purposes you have to do one after the
other
okay so for mightycall purposes if I
have to call AdMob twice at least you
have to do sequential e for that part
sequential or parallel it doesn't matter
so let's not get into that really the
mighty call is a big part here so the
mediation whether you do sequentially
apparently doesn't matter but there are
reasons where we have there it's done
sequentially okay it's really because
like if ad exchange is sitting here
right and you know you called so many
different exchanges but I'd exchange
basically wants a guarantee for instance
that if I'm returning an ad with a very
high probability you need to accept it
because I've already done an auction and
then you can't accept it because you run
you are also called other exchanges in
parallel and you are running an auction
on top of it and therefore you will with
a good probability reject Alex and
that's not the way contracts are right
but anyway doesn't matter whether that
is paralleling if you want think about
those things as in parallel but still a
plowing is getting called multiple times
in sequence which has to be in sequence
by definition descending prices and I'm
trying to get at extracting the whole
surplus in this process he needs that is
the price was not met otherwise that
exactly the chain will get terminated
there
there's no way you have to lower the
price between two different polls to
apply but say the first two you could
but also I think like that is a question
of how quickly you want to finish this
is like you know they did the the
mediation chain constructor is
constructing these things maybe they
have some time constraints on like you
know maybe you have a good leg you have
a feeling that you know from here to
here if I'm going to ask AdMob but
ninety four ninety nine they're going to
reject it so let's proceed quickly
instead of wasting time
[Music]
absolutely there's no reason for that
but still you could still imagine that
like I'm going to waste time by doing
this but anyway like the service
providers they do it anyway right that's
the interesting part here if it is all
like parallel which is it'll be exactly
a Dutch auction which is what I'm
getting to in the next slide
meaning if it is all like 100 hundred
hundred for everybody and then everybody
is getting called at ninety nine
everybody is getting called at ninety
eight that's like a Dutch auction which
is not the case here it's like a
non-transparent - yeah okay so how is
multi call implemented well the
publishers are altering easily spoof of
all attributes of a query like something
there's something called an ad slot code
you know which nobody knows what exactly
it means but for different records you
can change it and now you don't know
whether it's part of the same multi to
call query or is whether it's genuinely
a different query okay there are some
techniques to decide it but it's not
like hundred percent foolproof like
maybe it's genuinely two different
queries which look very you know it
close to one another it's a reduction in
by side is hard okay it's really hard to
say whether the same ad unit is being
resold or not same physical idea but
each of these guys is running an auction
rate like the other I'm going to talk
about the time like basically each like
phase like a blowing is going to call
all these and then they have to run
their internal auction presumably is
like you know sometimes the each of
these guys like each node could take a
around 500 milliseconds yeah I mean VII
yes yes
but still they I mean if you think about
like a single call like we are talking
about 200 to 300 milliseconds for
desktop like four because here to
today's experience is bad for app it's
better ok what are the consequences well
same as several bad consequences one is
that there's a huge increase in resource
cost because many big ad networks like
Google Display Network for instance they
are running their internal auctions
because they're representing thousands
of advertisers and now for each query
they have to each query in the multi
call sequence they have to run a
separate auction deciding who has to win
etc and retrieving the right ad from a
huge number of ads is really expensive
like it's all shouted across numerous
machines you have to go and get back
luggage it's a pretty non-trivial
problem
okay it's like the more it becomes like
the system will eventually melt after
some point like you know if your multi
calling excessively say in the
advertiser ROI suffers that should be
obvious thing because multi call is
trying to extract full surplus from
advertisers right and if you think
really that this query is not going to
come back because your name or you don't
really understand how this works then
you think okay ninety dollars he is
selling and they know my value is ninety
five perhaps I - you know I accepted it
at this point rather than like waiting
because you know it's going to come back
to me at 85 tomorrow right which may be
the right thing to do if you know that
water you know what's going ok so the
high-level question is how to you know
solve the multi call problem practical
like this is happening today that is the
question so basically how to do it is
the question I'm going to come to that
like basically if you don't like if you
for instance didn't know that multi call
is happening for instance or you
couldn't detect it's very hard to detect
actually right detecting is a
non-trivial problem
otherwise I do not know whether or not
either that or basically now it is like
common but even if they know it it's
very hard to know like at what price
you're going to get called next if you
and all your competitors are going to
get called at similar prices together
that's at least okay it's a Dutch
auction you know it's not like that
right because you know this guy you know
fan got to call it at 95 and AdMob got
called at 90 and so on yeah yeah I'm
thinking of it yeah basically that that
is practically solving the problem from
an ad networks point of view both in
terms of this terrible resource cost
wastage and in terms of ROI which is
what the ad network exists to provide
for its clients such as advertisers okay
the first round the reserve was made
that's iterated the chain stops so here
you're saying that for 99.99 like fan is
going to you know return an ad return
the bid at 80 let's say 95
okay you're saying they won't do this
call but that would be like bit cashing
right you're cashing the bid for a
different query and then you're
explicitly saying that I'm going to use
it for a different query because you are
after all telling it's like a different
query right you're changing the
attributes who knows I won't like this
ad slot code is too important for me
that's a scandal actually it's a scandal
and then addicts is the XO many networks
have reported about this bit cashing you
report some bit I'll store it freeze it
and then use it for another query okay
so that's problematic but anyway like
the bid itself might not come here
because fan looks at this reserve price
and then like you know says I won't bid
here because it's too much yeah but even
if you do that legate's it's a legal
trouble right okay so okay so initial
thought is you know why don't you like
prevent multi call it's strict policy
enforcement right one is that like that
ship has sailed
okay this is like multi call is there to
exist and then like publishers think of
it as a way to get better money etc and
this ad network which is pushing for
completely like enforcing very low
number of multi core calls will become
less popular the publisher and therefore
will have less access to the inventory
maybe they'll put you in the last of the
chain or something second is it's also
hard to enforce because you know how are
you going to like maybe you can detect
it for your own sake like you're 80%
sure but you have to present it to them
like that really it was a part of the
same ad unit that got sold and so on
okay so okay so is this a Dutch auction
that it's not quite a Dutch auction so
basically the point here was that
instead of these kind of policy things
there is you know we need to think about
game theoretic
Lucian's for some incentives based
solutions from the ad networks point of
view so if it were at that auction that
would be nice but it's the real problem
here is a non-transparent debt auction
right
you really don't know like what prices
you are skipping you your competition is
good call it some price you're skipping
some of the prices right and you thought
like maybe it's a putrid auction like
you know P dollars buying it at P is a
good thing but you never got called at P
and your competitors got called at P
they want it at P and then you're
waiting that's how this problem okay
that's right okay which is you know this
example just captures this point this is
clear right okay so okay so how do you
like solve the multi call problem right
like how do you analyze it for instance
there's also the first question is the
detection question how do you detect
multi call this is mostly an engineering
task but there are the modeling issues
to here like how close are the prices in
the successive calls you know the time
intervals between two calls there could
also be like intertwining like you know
the two genuinely different queries and
they are both intertwining like you know
one called it one hundred other called
at 90 and then one is going down like
this so it's very difficult even if you
have logs information to detect it so
that's it's a practical problem but
anyway like for game theory wise is
there anything like a multi call
equilibrium like if it exists at all
which is basically everyone is somehow
best responding the multi call chain
constructor whose goal is to maximize
revenue for the publisher is doing some
kind of non transparent Dutch auction
with this chain and then each ad network
knowing how other ad networks are like
throttling their queries which is
basically saying hey this 90 is the
bogus I'm going to wait for any 80 if
you know that other actors are going to
behave like this what would you do like
for waters like the equilibrium of the
system and what okay so as you were
let's say you assume 100% multi core
detection you really know that this
particular thing is going to come back
again it's a part of the same chain or
what if you are only able to say that
this this is basically the only
probability P that this is part of a
multi core maybe like you think this is
like some genuinely another thing which
won't come again later or something so
how would you think about it I think
that's the practical question here
they'll be formalized in respective New
Yorker or something this multicolored
they contain any stink from limit they
may actually want participate even in
Gujarat exchange themselves so that's
another level that they may after these
simply on the structures they make one
participate in some other yes they could
send a call like that's up to them they
they basically can go to any in extra
usually I mean the chain length is like
fifty or something that's please like
informal estimates but they're to stop
at some point because even for apps
there is a time training okay so these
are basically the questions here like
how do you analyze this non transparent
at auction make any modeling assumptions
you want there are different ways to do
this and then think about like what
happens the equilibrium is this a good
behave like is this a good outcome fair
ad networks don't you know made them
sort of burn themselves by repeatedly
running this very expensive internal
auctions themselves for each
setup price for good and the bias
incentives to wait yeah the cost
connection and durable goods monopoly
where you're competing with your own
future prices right yeah but okay so in
this case if you if you don't know what
your competitors are going to do what
does it say your ad network and you
don't know like wow how your competitors
are going to respond for instance maybe
one of them is really aggressive because
they have a lot of budget they want to
spend it so in this chain like you know
oh yes I know that the price is going to
go down but you know one of the networks
is aggressive and that they are going to
get it and you don't know how aggressive
they are which have like different
chains constructed for them different
links let's forget about budget
constraints for now like you usually
it's always a question of like they want
to spend everything and sometimes they
work like this these are networks are
aggressively spending money usually on
that side that if you if you live if
you're left with money on the table
that's problematic because it's still a
constraint I'm saying it's not it's okay
yes there exists some budget constraint
like but that's not the first order
thing if you want to model this you can
make necessary to worry about yes this
trick we can solve that problem for
instance that would be very nice if you
analyze the single query in isolation
and solve this is interesting
people are shedding their bits of the
North America it's like other they took
platform one that uses particle about
which to us
it's very hard to say that right like
how do you break what does it mean
because each query is different there is
like a whole vector of features for this
query and then the next query is
different and there's a time of the day
and so I don't know what it means to
figure out that they really shared it
because of this but definitely like
since this is a common phenomenon these
sophisticated ad networks will shape
unless they are aggressively like they
want to win it very soon they want to
spend all the budget that said that that
behavior is also there is some
irrationality yes yes they they're
responsible for shading they are
responsible for doing that but what from
what I have heard like many of them like
their did they think about like bidding
very differently than in game theoretic
terms they are thinking about like how
to spend all this money because if they
if some money is left on the table
that's like a big deal because they
they're really for advertisers reaches
maximum oil it would certainly not we
have to moderate hours usually it's
decreasing yeah there are some equations
weird cases where it increases but again
we are not sure right we are just like
positing that these are the chains and
for for the most part it is decreasing
so that I think that's a reasonable
assumption that part we are here we can
assume reasonably well so in terms of
potential reasons probably you're going
to what we call problem the reason is
the problem is that the allocation isn't
efficient or that there's a lot of
wasted energy and running all of these
auctions or do you view those as kind of
on comparable scales is one of these are
much bigger concern to you than others I
think both are problematic like this
this resource wastage is a big problem
particularly the bigger that network is
for the same ad unit you're spending a
lot of money but the advertiser ROI is
also reasonably important right because
ultimately like these are networks
represent their clients this way so they
are going to look for our way
the cost of running these auctions
relative to say the surplus available to
advertisers through them when the
evidence is you can just look at these
chains and ask how often you know the
and advertisers are clear at the top of
the chain and the same like ad network
clear later in the chain and for similar
looking queries for instance where
presumably they have the same value and
then ask like if most of the clearance
is happening early on in the chain but
the you know for the same query they
have also cleared later within with a
non mediation provider at a much lower
surprise and perhaps then that they got
ripped off here or something I mean
meaning like they could have like easily
gotten a much higher surplus without
this right
electricity is cheap but I also know
that the cost of an individual in
question may not be that high so I don't
have a good electricity because you are
talking about tens of thousands of
advertisers who are shattered in
different machines and I have to
retrieve all of them and run trade it's
not cheap so what do you mean where
electricity is cheap I mean we're taking
is very small number we're multiplying
it by a very big number and I don't have
a sense of getting of like whether it's
a negligible quantity in the end or
whether it's like so display ads
marketplace itself is like only badly
profit-making cried because of all the
cost ad server itself is like a huge
like hugely costly operation and if you
are like burdens like this on top of it
it becomes problematic
or for platforms like running ad server
Vegas is a very costly operation okay so
the next is you might have heard or read
about this that many exchanges have
moved to first price auctions and the
Google's articles will be doing soon so
how should we think about rizzo pricing
in first price auctions what does it
even mean so first of all why reserve
price right the problem is that as
targeting technologies get better and
better auctions have become quite thin
okay so you have very few participants
in the auction and if auctions are thin
then competition alone is not enough to
drive revenue okay so there are numerous
reasons for it but practically speaking
like advertisers want transparency that
is I pay what I bid because there were
like numerous unscrupulous exchanges out
there which claimed that they were
running second price auction but then
they were doing all sorts of things like
there are some soft floors where like
you know you there's a soft floor
meaning that if you clear the floor you
pay that floor but even if you don't
clear that floor you continue to win the
auction but pay the first price bid and
then there's a hard floor once you clear
that once you fall below that you get
filtered so it's a it's they call it a
second price auction but nobody will
give it in writing that this is it right
so there is something like a first price
auction it's a convex combination of
first and second prize who knows what is
going on right because I pay you know I
never know what I'm going to get be
paying once I bid this in a first price
auction although that is the burden
shifted to me in terms of strategizing
second price auction a statistically
trivial first price auction there's a
fantasy involved at the very least I
know that I am going to pay what a bit
so there is this transparency there and
there was a big call for this because of
all these practices and exceed that or
exchange started moving to this
okay so why do you want a resort price
you want to reserve price because
competition is just not enough to give
good yield for publishers and often the
difference between the highest and the
second highest bid is huge okay it's not
uncommon to have this difference to be
larger than the second highest bid
itself the discount is huge so you need
to put a reserve price in between this
is the display at auctions Google's is a
completely different market play rate
there is not this like the for answering
that question photosynthesis all this
unscrupulous competition I was talking
about that landscape which pressured
like this change to first place auction
and transparency and so on right Google
search is a completely different
landscape we don't have that kind of
problems where there is like numerous
exchanges running whatever so this is
this is all for none of this is for
searches all for display ads okay so it
is or pricing so in reso pricing and
second price auctions is simple right
you have n buyers at values like this
and suppose you managed to put a reserve
price between v1 and v2 then you
increase the sellers revenue by r minus
v2 but crucially without needing any
buyer reaction right the previous query
they reacted like this and then like you
know they bid like this is a next query
for a similar-looking query I put this
reserve price then without any reaction
you're still making this money but in a
fast price auction let's say buyers are
bidding like this and you manage to
luckily find a reserve price in between
these two which is hard because
obviously the surprise are sent before
the bits right you're sending it in a
call-out even if you luckily happen to
find this thing it's a no op right
because they're going to pay their bid
the highest guy is going to pay b1
but in reality its revenue negative
because FR happens to be larger than b1
you are killing the query so trivially
reser pricing and first price auction is
revenue negative so what are you hoping
the only thing you could hope for is
that buyers are reacting to the
surprises right reacting to the
surprises and changing their pitch in
response to that because anyway they're
they're doing some shading originally
they were not building properly but then
now this reserve price for
they will raise their bid that's the
hope but then there is a long term as a
short term by a response short term
means instantaneously when I send a
reserve price they're going to respond
to that in the bid that are sending me
let us think of two bits to call outs in
one call out the reserve price is zero
in another call out to the same hundred
as the same query I am sending a reserve
prices is non zero perhaps they'll
change their billed in response to this
if they do that that is good if they
don't do that
they're just updating their bidding
models on a day to day basis or a week
to week basis seeing like how much how
they are performing on the KPIs right
then that's a long-term question now the
a/b test which is the gold standard for
making decisions and all big companies
will completely fail to capture the
long-term effect it will only capture
the short-term reaction right because
you know you have this treatment effect
you're treating some advertisers and
you're asking like hey what happened and
if they didn't react in short-term
always you're a B test is going to show
that reserve pricing is there any
negative so measuring the long-term
effect itself is a non-trivial problem
and there are beautiful causal inference
questions here right so first is we need
to treat advertisers not queries right
advertisers are our experimental units
here to see what they're doing but we
can only treat queries obviously it's a
fizzer price and queries now if you
treat a random fraction of queries then
an advertiser might only see a fraction
of their queries affected and they are
not going to change that bidding
behavior and what you're measuring is
not what you're supposed to measure on
the other hand
okay so then what do we need here well
there's a common assumption and causal
inference called suit war which is
stable unit treatment value assumption
which says that the outcome of a
treatment unit is independent of how
other units are treated which fails here
right which means in the presence of
interference there is interference
effect between like different queries or
different experimental units you need
some kind of balanced partitioning of
the graph on experimental units to do
this right of course this is np-hard
problem in balanced partitioning you can
only approximately minimize the
interference you cannot always eliminate
it and even the problem of if I give you
two partitions of a graph deciding which
partition you should pick which is going
to give a you know more unbiased this is
already non-trivial there's a paper
recently on this so there are definitely
some nice questions to be answered here
like how to set up this long term
experiment and how are you going to
measure the long term effects further
complications to this which is I keep
saying advertisers but it's not really
advertisers it's ad networks on the side
and each ad network is representing
multiple advertisers which ash with the
complication of this treatment effect so
this is again a very current problem
it's far from solid even practically
speaking it's low now other is providing
bidding tools for advertisers in first
price auctions because many ad networks
are still not ready to build in a first
price auction so in these cases ad
exchanges are providing bid translation
services they say I know only how to
build in a second price auction so ad
networks say that I'll provide this
translation service and this is how it
works
so the same exchange will have some ad
networks participating in second price
auction and the others participating in
first place what does it mean for all
those who have opted to participate in
the second prize will run a second price
auction and then the winner of the
second price auction will participate in
a first price auction with the rest and
then we will provide a bit translation
service where we'll take the clearing
price the highest buying the second
highest and then translate it to a bid
to participate in the first price
auction how do you do it
so the initial simple solution is you
just forward the clearing price and the
second price auction well this is bad
because often could be too low okay like
particularly given what I said before
that there could be huge difference
between first and second highest this
guy won't be winning anything in the
first price auction or you could send
the true or high the value itself but
then they add part is the what's the
whole point of bit translation like if
you send the true value you're bidding
too high in the auction that's going to
cause loss of surplus so the goal is to
protect advertiser surplus in these bid
translation services but also like you
should not eat up too much into
publisher revenue because they
themselves are badly floating like most
publishers really need this money also
and advertisers are aware of this so the
other is other kind of bidding tool is
like providing a bidding dashboard okay
so it can be provide some kind of a
bidding dashboard to guide the buyers to
a good equilibrium if there was like a
paper in the cc-cold dashboard
mechanisms so this is not too
far-fetched actually because Google
itself for instance in AdWords we
provide like some kind of dashboard
which gives a landscape information this
is your cost versus like what you can
win if you paid this much you can win
this much right there's a landscape like
this given and then buyers respond to
that landscape somehow the main idea
here in this paper at least is that
aydin's are unable to arrive at
equilibrium but they are at least able
to best respond to the dashboard right
if I give you this dashboard and I tell
you that I'm going to implement what I
promised in the dashboard you can at
least best respond to that dashboard is
basically a landscape like this right
I'm going to give you this this is
basically the dashboard I'll give you a
whole curve like this if you spend this
much then you will get these many
impressions if you spend that much you
will get those many impressions like a
cost versus a probability of allocation
curve
so you need not worry about competition
or anything somehow all that has been
rolled into this dashboard and you past
that the publisher of the dashboard
provider knows better and they will give
this they will you know they will be
consistent to what they reported and
therefore you best respond given the
dashboard rather than best responding to
any yeah so initially okay so let's
think of initially you don't know
anything as a publisher of the dashboard
provider like all the value likes
private values and prior free you don't
have any prize nothing so initially your
dashboard is complete [ __ ] because
like you can't give anything but slowly
it'll get better
assuming either persistent values which
is what they do in this paper for the
most part or if values change across
time they maybe you should have like
clever ways of slowly changing value
this is also your like reasonable
because you're talking about like
similar queries at least in the given
sequence like long-lived agents what can
you do so those are some interesting
which are not actually tackled properly
in that paper like a values change
slowly but you still want to provide
dashboard consistency which is what you
were getting at which is how can you be
like you promised something but you have
to deliver what you promised right
otherwise there won't be best responding
even then there is a question of like
they didn't give what they promised but
it was still not too far in that case
perhaps it's still better to best
respond to the dashboard and then doing
something on your own because yeah
there's still value in that second is
like yeah this is to what extent can you
tolerate value chain how much value
change can you change tolerate as the
dashboard provider over time yeah I
think there are some interesting
questions here nice follow-ups to the
sir
[Applause]
moving the marketplace is very different
right because the there are so many
exchanges running these auctions and
certainly like you know Google or
Facebook or these are the only thing
there's so many exchanges providing
these services and each one has their
own way of doing things which is unlike
the search landscape and therefore there
are some trust issues here this is one
of the biggest drivers in doing this and
down at the big differences there is
real time building in display ads which
is not the case and surcharges make
another big difference yes yes that's
true yes but these others went to first
place because of these kinds of things
like yeah yes anyway they were doing
something like a first price at least
now they announce that is the first
price because you make but is that is
soft flooring right I put a reserve
price completely independent of anything
and then wait for you to respond that's
like that's fine right if I pray the
surprise properly it's not first pricing
it's still full truthful and yes
offloading is different that is the bad
practice right and that is why I like
these exchanges we're doing this and
like because Google is bidding in many
of these like we're good bids like the
booth at a Google buyers who bid in
other networks also other exchanges also
you can measure these things and yeah
like you can see the soft curves pretty
clearly it's nothing if there are two
floors there's off flow to the higher
floor and there is a hard floor if you
are higher than the soft floor let's say
you're the only bidder which is like it
in action right here to Rizzo prices if
you're higher than soft flow you pay
this off floor if you're between a soft
in the hard floor you pay your bill
itself so you're below the soft floor
you filter the query
so in the in the dashboard idea
I wonder if the platforms
I may have for incentives to not to be
toasting here if they say the last one
wants to make the bit higher than today
to have been in place for the video
getting an airplane going to be higher
modern monetary interface
ah these are a way to sort of
incentivize the other hand in some way
because it sounded like we say is they
asked the isn't program only by the by
the platform is that problem here so
sorry okay so option circumstances
I don't know what are the transparency
issue with the dashboard rail because
once you provide a dashboard and your
Blake's life you know you're going to be
held like you know somebody's going to
ask like whether you're consistent or
not that's transfer aggregate fashion
it's not too hard that's what it shows
the curve telling you you know the
relationship between the bidding price
and they probably don't win my soul yes
[ __ ] like probability of winning you
should think of it as total number of
impressions right so at the end of the
day you go and count like you know you
have good reporting's you are an
advertiser who's like an ad network is
providing nice reporting to you you go
and see like whether really it matched
up right they can like it's it's I don't
think transparency is a big issue here
but like really constant like providing
a dashboard where you can be consistent
in spite of like value changes and so on
instead of making us the trivial
assumption that values are persistent
across time how to tackle general single
parameter I mean for although we're
talking about one item auctions in these
things like I think theoretically
speaking
think about the same agenda single
diverse today oil happened in those are
interesting
[Applause]